football frenzy on the streets of Gaza
decorations and flags representing all
of the World Cup football teams are
hanging in cafes throughout the besieged
causes strip but Palestinians joy and
excitement will have to stay here
while people of many countries are
traveling to Qatar to watch the World
Cup most people in Gaza cannot Israel's
Siege of the occupied territory its
restriction on the movement of its
people and the dire economy make it
nearly impossible
people in other parts of the world would
Gather in their homes to watch the game
but most gazans don't have that luxury
while watching the tournament at home is
common around the world here in Gaza
it's become a luxury power outages mean
most people only have electricity for
about six to eight hours a day most
football fans have to find cafes with
generators to watch the matches for free
and there is also a huge outdoor screen
provided by Qatar for people to follow
the tournament known by some as the
Mondial
our aim is to allow the resident of the
besieged Gaza to live the atmosphere of
the tournament as if he's in one of
Qatar stadiums many of those who can't
travel can't even watch the matches in
cafes because of their financial
conditions
although the
Dynamic condition
have money in Gaza people are doing all
they can to enjoy the event
we've made some preparations here we've
hired more staff and installed new
screens and Internet service we expect
to receive a lot of fans because people
can't afford to pay the be in sports
subscription to watch the matches and
most don't have generators to overcome
power Cuts
despite all challenges one thing is
certainly gossip the love of the gay
triumphs all
you may see it Al Jazeera Gaza